No gatekeeping here.
Happy to share the recipe.
You preheat your oven to 400 degrees,
lightly toast some breadcrumbs in a pan with some butter,
and obviously boil noodles whatever shape you like.
I like to grate my cheese fresh,
so I work on that while the noodles are boiling.
And then making macaroni and cheese is a very simple ratio.
It's for every tablespoon of butter,
you add a tablespoon of flour
and then one cup of milk and then one cup of cheese.
Those are all the things that go together. And it's all the same number,
the same ratio.
1 1 1 1 or 2 2, 2 2.
So you cook the roux down,
that's just the flour in the butter.
Season it a little bit lightly,
cause this will be a good time to get the flavors
deep down in the heart and soul of your macaroni and cheese.
When you add the milk in,
add it very slowly at first,
otherwise it could get really clumpy.
You're gonna kind of wanna,
you know, you gotta mix it together nicely.
You don't let it come to a boil.
Just when it starts to simmer and just start to bubble,
pull it off the heat and then add in the cheeses.
I added a white cheddar and then a yellow cheddar.
And then save a little bit of that cheese
so that after you get the noodles mixed up with the sauce,
you can put some of That cheese on top.
Cause we are gonna bake it in the oven.
And here's the thing I love about these pans.
When you put it in the oven,
you can take the handle off
so you can really shove it in the back of the oven
and not have to worry about leaving room for the handle.
So once you get all the cheese and the bread crumbs
all evenly spread on top,
you pop it in that preheated oven at 400 degrees for about 15 minutes.
And this was the final result.
It is absolutely delicious.
I kind of do think it tastes better the next day,
but that's up to you.
You decide if you want these pans.
They're LinkedIn the TikTok shop.
They are amazing.
They're nonstick,
non toxic. They're ceramic coated,
so they're not Teflon,
they have no toxic ingredients.
And look how amazing they clean out like nothing.
Takes two seconds to clean.